This mundane house mouse
may hold clues to
when and how humans
first started farming
The question is: did people first settle down
you know, become sedentary
and then later start farming
or was farming the catalyst
that made people stay in one place?
So was it
hunter-gatherer, sedentism, and then farming
OR
hunter-gatherer, farming, and then sedentism
To figure this out, researchers looked at
the distribution of fossilized mouse teeth
From wild mice and house mice
They wanted to know when
house mice began dominating their wild cousins--
suggesting the house mice were living
close to humans
who had been there for a while,
enjoying their shelters and leftovers
According to their results,
the house mouse
formed a beneficial relationship with people
15,000 years ago
This was before farming,
so that means people were
hunting and gathering in one place
long enough for house mice
to form a relationship with them
and out-compete their wild cousins
in the same location
So in this case is looks like it was
hunter-gatherer, sedentism, farming
NOT
hunter-gatherer, farming, then sedentism
As a side note:
It’s possible that this is why
you don’t see hunter-gatherers
domesticating cats
until after they transitioned to farming.
Before there was grain for them to poach,
the mice weren’t considered pests,
so no need to keep kitties around to control them.
So looking at mouse teeth in different locations
may give us new insights into how this transition
to farming happened around the world